[SQUEAKING]
[RUSTLING]
[CLICKING]
JOHN DOLHUN: Welcome to
the ferrocene lecture.
We are going to do a
demonstration at the start
because I'm going to be talking
about additional reactions
during this lecture.
And I want you to
actually see one happen.
So I've got Amanda
Trainor, who is
manning the fire extinguisher.
Amanda just had her fire
extinguisher testing.
So she is ready to go.
And Dr. Sarah
Hewett will actually
assist me with the
bromine that we're using.
Bromine and me go way back
because I made bromine
when I was in high school.
In the parents of my--
in my parents' home--
in the basement.
The whole place filled up
with reddish brown gas.
And back in those days,
the chemistry sets
had real chemicals in them.
So what we're going to do is we
are going to cook some bacon.
And we are going to
crack the glycerol.
And we going to make this
unsaturated compound acrolein.
Then we're going to throw
it into the bromine.
And the bromine should add
across the double bond--
an addition reaction.
This is the acrid
smelly stuff that you
smell when you cook bacon.
This is the burned bacon
fat smell that you smell.
It's colorless, flammable,
and very poisonous.
So let's go.
We're going to start this.
So I'm using a
creme brulee torch.
It's my wife's.
She's probably out of her
mind now looking for it.
So we're cooking the bacon.
And we're going to get that
bacon fat-- the glycerol--
broken down.
Ready?
And here we go.
So we've thrown the
bacon into the bromine.
You can start to see
the color disappearing.
Color is adding across the
double bond of the bacon.
And I present to
you bacon dibromide.
Good stuff.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.
I actually don't
eat a lot of bacon
anymore after doing this demo
knowing that stuff is so nasty
and a cancer producer too.
So all right.
Let me get this
hot lab coat off.
So Emil Fischer and
Geoffrey Wilkinson
win the Nobel Prize
in chemistry back
in 1973 for their
independent work looking
at these organo-metallic
sandwich like compounds.
It all started here in
1951 with a paper published
by Pauson and
Keely, "In Nature,"
where they took a Grignard
like reagent cyclopentadienyl
magnesium bromide.
And they tried to get an
oxidative coupling of this ring
hoping to make fulvalene.
Instead, they got this
stable orange complex.
Empirical formula C10H10Fe.
Right after this paper came
out the fellow on the right,
Geoffrey Wilkinson, who was at
MIT, had just moved to Harvard.
And both him and Woodward at
Harvard looked at this paper
and said, wait a minute.
With these sigma
metal carbon bonds
they're saying that
this complex actually
is stable at very high
temperatures up to 400 degrees.
So that these bonds
would disintegrate
at those temperatures.
So they were skeptical
of this structure.
So they immediately said, well,
let's do an addition reaction.
Look at all the
double bonds here.
Should easily be able to
do an addition reaction
and add across
those double bonds.
They got no reaction.
So then they said, OK.
Just for the fun, let's try
a substitution reaction.
For a substitution reaction
you need an aromatic system
such as benzene.
An electrophilic aromatic
substitution reaction
involves an electrophile,
which simply substitutes itself
for a hydrogen on
the aromatic ring
and gives you your product.
So they tried a
substitution reaction
and they actually
got a reaction.
Now they were a little bit
more puzzled because look
at cyclopentadiene.
Is it aromatic?
How many pi electrons are there?
Four.
Good.
And what is Huckel's rule?
Anyone know Huckel's rule?
Yeah?
Sean?
AUDIENCE: Pi electrons
are at the aromatic.
JOHN DOLHUN: OK.
AUDIENCE: So this would
be [INAUDIBLE] aromatic.
JOHN DOLHUN: That's
one way to look at it.
So Huckel's rule is 4n plus 2.
Right?
4n plus 2 pi electrons where n
is a 0 or any positive integer
from 1 up.
If you put 0 in there
you get two electrons.
That obviously has four.
If you put one in
there you get six.
So this definitely does
not observe Huckel's rule.
It's not aromatic.
Most of these types of
hydrocarbons like this
have PKAs that are
greater than 50.
But it turns out
that cyclopentadiene
has these hydrogens
on there that
are slightly acidic because its
conjugate base is very stable--
stabilized by resonance.
So if we take a--
where did I put my chalk, here.
If we take a base here,
come in and abstract one
of those protons, what we're
going to get is this anion.
And this is the
cyclopentadienide anion.
This has six electrons.
Now if you look at this system--
all of these SP2
hybridized carbon atoms
now have electron density
that they can share
all around that entire ring.
So this is an aromatic system.
And what would Geoffrey
Wilkinson and Woodward said
was, OK, so let's
take two of these,
make kind of like a
sandwich structure--
six electrons on the bottom,
six electrons on the top,
and six D electrons
from iron in the center.
So you've got 18 electrons.
That's kind of a magic number
for an inorganic chemist
because it's got that
noble gas configuration.
So the D electrons
from the iron are
pi bonding with the P electrons
from the hydrocarbons.
This is a complete reversal
of the classical way
of looking at ligand
metal bond coordination.
Everybody used the sigma bonds.
No one ever thought
about pi bonds.
Can I have two volunteers?
Yes.
Come on up.
Come on.
See if you can come over to
the front of the table here.
And you are?
AUDIENCE: Aisha.
JOHN DOLHUN: Aisha.
And?
AUDIENCE: Maya.
JOHN DOLHUN: Maya.
OK.
Aisha and Maya.
So let's see what mama
packed me for lunch today.
Oh good.
I got two pieces of bread here.
Correct.
OK.
So Aisha, why don't
you hold the bread--
one hand like that and
stagger the other one
and put a space between it
and turn toward this way.
Yeah.
Turn so it's-- yeah.
Put the crust facing
the audience on one
and away from the
audience on the other.
Maya, take the orange.
And now let's see.
Let's fix this a little bit.
So there we go.
And come down a little bit.
Now Maya, come in.
Put the orange right there.
There it is.
[LAUGHTER]
A molecular sandwich.
That's ferrocene-- the two
cyclopentadienide anions
and the iron atom in
the middle pi bonding
with all their electrons.
Congratulations.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
Maya, do you like the orange?
AUDIENCE: Sure, thank you.
JOHN DOLHUN: I know you don't
want the bread, but oh, look.
There's something else.
Here.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
JOHN DOLHUN: OK.
So we just figured out how
ferrocene is put together.
Now we have to make it.
And to make ferrocene
you need cyclopentadiene.
But this stuff is not
commercially available
because it has a half
life of 12 hours.
What it does is it
spontaneously adds
to itself in this reverse
Diels-Alder type reaction
to make the dimer.
So let's look at the Diels-Alder
reaction for a moment.
If you're taking
organic now, this
is the Mona Lisa of all organic
reactions discovered by Otto
Diels and Kurt Alder in 1928.
And they both won the
Nobel Prize in 1950.
You need a diene--
an unsaturated hydrocarbon
with two double bonds--
and a dienophile--
a substituted alkene-- to make
this substituted cyclohexene
type derivative.
What you've got is
four pi electrons here,
two pi electrons here,
and this is called
a 4 plus 2 cyclo addition.
And this reaction just goes.
You don't have to do it.
You put them
together and it goes
because you're making
these sigma bonds, which
are much more energetically
stable than the pi
bonds you're starting with.
But look at our system.
We have these two
cyclopentadiene rings.
We don't have a dienophile.
We've got two dienes here.
And this thing still goes
spontaneously-- adds to itself
to produce the dimer and
other higher polymers.
So how are we
going to make this?
We're going to crack the
dicyclopentadiene in the hood.
The TAs are going
to do this for you.
It's highly flammable--
the product.
Cyclopentadiene is
highly flammable
so they're going
to cool it in ice.
The other thing is,
this is very smelly.
So don't wear your silk clothes
and your wool clothes to lab
when you're making this stuff.
So you're going to be
going over to the hood
to get your allocation.
The main thing you
have to be aware of
is when you get your
needle and you put it in
and you pull your 0.3 mLs--
whatever you need for
your reaction vessel--
that you don't grab on to
the syringe with your fingers
because the warmth
of your fingers
will dimerize this
right in the syringe
before you inject it into
your reaction vessel.
We're going to heat this
up to about 180 degrees,
collect the fraction that comes
over between 38 and 41 degrees.
That's our cyclopentadiene.
Now we're going
to be using no air
techniques in some of the
experiments that we're doing.
Why do you think we need
to use no air techniques?
Yes?
Alex?
AUDIENCE: There are things
in the air like oxygen
that are reactive.
JOHN DOLHUN: Very good.
There's oxygen in the air
that's very reactive so some
of the chemicals you're using
like iron chloride tetrahydrate
could be oxidized.
We've also got that
cyclopentadienide anion here,
which--
this guy-- which actually
decomposes in the air.
So it's very important
to have this atmosphere.
So how are you going to do that?
Pretty simple.
We're going to be working
with these little vessels.
They're called Assem vials.
They have septums on them.
So you'll put your
reactants in there.
And then you'll simply
take a vent needle,
put a vent needle
in into the septum.
Don't push the vent
needle down too far.
If you push it down
too far, your liquid
might shoot up through
the vent needle.
Then you're going to
go over to the hood.
You're going to pull
out the nitrogen line.
Nitrogen will be flowing.
You'll stick the
nitrogen line in.
Now you're bubbling nitrogen in.
And this can go down
into the liquid, bubble,
get it refreshed.
Then you're pushing out the
air through the vent needle.
After a couple of minutes,
take the vent needle out.
And then pull out
the nitrogen line.
Now you effectively have
a nitrogen atmosphere
for your reaction.
So this is the reaction scheme
for the synthesis of ferrocene.
Notice there are two
reactions going on here.
You'll actually have two
of these little asam vials.
In one of them you're going to
have KOH and dimethoxyethane.
The KOH you'll have to mass
out at the balance area.
And you've got to
work kind of quickly
with this because KOH
is very hygroscopic.
It picks up water very quickly.
In the other vessel
you're going to put
iron chloride tetrahydrate
dimethyl sulfoxide.
And then you're going
to shake those vessels.
You're going to
work out in the lab.
You seriously-- you will be
sore after this lab for about
an hour of working out.
Once you shake them well, your
iron chloride tetrahydrate
should dissolve.
But the KOH will not dissolve.
So don't worry about that.
Do you see KOH?
It's OK.
Once you get
everything dissolved
you take your iron chloride--
or your KOH dimethoxyethane
vessel over to the hood and you
get your cyclopentadienide
and you inject it.
You put that back under
an inert atmosphere.
And then you start
shaking it some more.
After about five minutes you
have this beautiful pink color,
which is your
cyclopentadienide anion--
sometimes called the Cp ligand
that's forming in your flask.
Let's just stand
back for a moment
and take a look at
that top reaction.
Who can tell me the driving
force of that reaction?
Why does that reaction go?
Alex?
AUDIENCE: It's an
acid base reaction.
JOHN DOLHUN: It's an
Yeah.
What else up there do you see
that just pushes that so fast?
Alex?
AUDIENCE: Resonance.
JOHN DOLHUN: Resonance.
OK.
Yeah.
You're making something
that has resonance forms.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Creating
the aromatic ring.
JOHN DOLHUN: Giselle, right?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
JOHN DOLHUN: Yes.
You're creating
an aromatic ring.
Very good.
So you're going from
a non aromatic system
to an aromatic system.
That is a big push.
OK.
So once you make this, then
what you're going to do
is you're going to take your
other vessel with the iron
chloride dimethyl
sulfoxide and you're
going to start doing injections.
You're going to do four
injections into this system.
After each injection--
when I did this
I usually put my system back
under an inert atmosphere.
And then I'd shake it.
Then I'd do another injection.
Shake it.
Inert atmosphere and so on.
And then finally, what you've
made is you made ferrocene.
So once you get down
here you're ready to take
a look at that ferrocene.
So what you're going
to need is you're
going to need a small beaker--
about a 30 mL beaker.
And then you half
fill it with ice.
So we're going to have
ice in the beaker.
And you're going to
add to the beaker
about 4.5 mols of 6 molar HCl.
And then you'll add your
ferrocene from your asam vial.
You're going to
add your ferrocene.
And when you do that, you
stir it up with your stir bar.
And you can use a little bit
of dimethoxyethane methane
to wash out your asam vial.
Get everything out, washed
out into that beaker.
And your orange crystals
should float to the top.
Once you get your
orange crystals,
you're going to set up a
little mini Buchner funnel
system such as this.
And inside of this there's a
baby piece of filter paper.
You want to be sure that
you wet this filter paper
and put it in wet.
Otherwise if you
don't, if it's dry,
your product will go under
it and end up in the flask.
So wet the filter paper,
pour your product in.
This is hooked up to
the vacuum in the lab.
And it will just
draw your product
and you'll have your
filtrate will come through.
Now the filtrate
that's coming through
is going to be a
bluish green color.
What do you think the
filtrate could be?
Anyone?
I know you know Alex.
Anyone else?
Alex, go for it.
AUDIENCE: Iron 3.
JOHN DOLHUN: Iron 3.
Oxidized ferrocene.
Interesting.
So you actually
started with ferrocene.
And in the process
of oxidation--
and you've got
some HCl in there.
So you've got chloride there.
So what we've made
here is-- you've
made what's called
ferrocenium chloride.
Why do you think we made that?
What does that represent?
Looks like we lost
some ferrocene probably
because we didn't
keep that right inert
atmosphere all along the way.
So think about how
you would take this
and get ferrocene back from it.
I'll let you think
about that a little bit.
If anybody comes up
with a great idea
and wants to do this on day four
when there's no lab going on,
let me know what you need.
OK?
So now, we've made
our ferrocene.
We've got our crude ferrocene
and we're going to purify it.
And we're going to
purify it by sublimation.
Definition of sublimation is the
amount of energy and kilojoules
per mole that we need to
add to one mole of a solid
to take it from the solid
to the gas directly.
Hess's Law defines the
enthalpy of sublimation
as the enthalpy of melting plus
the enthalpy of vaporization.
But for this to hold,
both of these steps
would have to be taking place
at the same temperature,
otherwise Hess's Law is
just an approximation.
I brought some
carbon dioxide in.
Can you see this?
It's subliming.
It's going from the solid--
and this is very cold stuff.
This is about minus 78 degrees.
I'm going to burn my hands.
So I'm doing this very quickly.
OK.
You can't see the sublimation
when it gets into the air.
But I'm going to put
it in this cylinder
so you can actually see the
bubbles of sublimation that
are taking place.
AUDIENCE: Woah.
Cool.
JOHN DOLHUN: So there's another
definition of sublimation
that we can use.
We can define it as heating a
solid below its triple point
to the gas and then collecting
that vapor on a cold surface.
And that's exactly
what you're going to do
with your crude ferrocene.
You're going to take a
biological culture dish,
sprinkle some of your
ferrocene in there,
cover it, put it on a hot
plate, and then fill up
a beaker with ice.
Put the beaker on top of it.
Turn the heat on.
Keep it under 100 degrees.
And after a few minutes, you'll
see orange ferrocene start
to sublime up inside
of the culture dish.
And then your crystals
will form on the bottom
of the cold part of the
dish and hang off the dish.
It's quite a dramatic reaction.
And this sublimation
is really great
because oftentimes the things
that you're trying to purify
are more volatile than the
impurities that they contain.
So it's very clean to
actually get a pure substance
from sublimation.
Couple precautions-- when
this reaction is over,
if you take your beaker like
this and you lift it up,
you're going to lose
all your product.
It'll fall right off.
You'll have to start over.
So the trick is to slide
the beaker off very gently.
The other thing you
don't want to do
is you don't want open
this dish when it's hot.
Why wouldn't we want
to this when it's hot?
Alex?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JOHN DOLHUN: Yeah.
The toxic ferrocene would
go up all around us.
We'd be breathing again.
So keep this closed
till it's cool.
Then open it up, scrape
your crystals off.
So now, you've made
your ferrocene.
So what we'd like to do is
we'd like to write a reaction.
And then you're
going to calculate
the limiting reagent,
the theoretical yield
from your starting materials.
You'll take your actual yield
and calculate a percent yield.
Let's just do a--
just to review-- a
general equation for that.
We'll do 2A plus B
going to C plus D.
And we're going to have 0.9
moles of A and 0.5 moles of B.
And I want to know how much
C can be formed theoretically
from my starting materials.
First thing to do is
look at the equation.
The equation is talking to you.
What is it saying?
It says for every 2A I
need one B. All right.
How much B do I have?
0.5.
So how much A do I need?
1.
I don't have enough.
That's your limiting reagent.
Right?
It's going to run out
before anything else.
So A is going to
determine your product.
So now again, take a
look at the equation.
It's talking.
For every 2A, you
make one C. How much
C am I going to make
from 0.9 moles of A?
0.45.
Very good.
So my theoretical yield is
going to be 0.45 moles of C.
Now what you can do
now is you're going
to actually do the reaction.
You'll mass out how
much you actually
got so you'll know what
your actual yield is.
So you can calculate
a percent yield,
which is your actual over
your theoretical times 100.
Pretty simple.
You're also going to have to
determine the melting point
of the ferrocene.
And I'm going to tell you that
if you take your melting point
tube and you stick it in
the melt temp and you're
watching it, you'll never see
it melt. Think about that.
Think about what
you're going to have
to do before you put
that melting tube
into the melting point
machine because you
know ferrocene sublimes.
Right?
Just going to disappear on you.
Think about that.
So now we are going
to take our ferrocene
and we're going to
do a Friedel-Crafts
electrophilic aromatic
substitution reaction.
We're going to
take the ferrocene
and we're going
to a acetylate it.
And normally this
Friedel-Crafts reaction
is usually done with a
very strong Lewis acid.
Usually they use
aluminum chloride.
But aluminum chloride is
very difficult to work with.
You take that stuff and
you're walking around with it
in the lab.
It's producing
hydrochloric acid gas.
So it reacts with the
water vapor in the air.
It's nasty.
So we have decided to use a much
weaker Lewis acid-- phosphoric
acid.
The good thing is that this
cyclopentadienide anion
is more reactive than benzene.
So we can get away with
this weaker Lewis acid.
So we've got acetic
anhydride phosphoric acid.
There are no solvents
in this reaction.
We're reacting these two
things with the ferrocene.
What do you think the phosphoric
acid is reacting with?
Anyone?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Is it activating
[INAUDIBLE] carbonyl?
JOHN DOLHUN: Yes.
It's actually
activating something
to produce an electrophile,
which is good.
And that's what we
need for this reaction.
So it's actually reacting
with the acetic anhydride.
And here it is here.
You can see the
mechanism of this.
Pretty simple.
The acetic anhydride
phosphoric acid react.
And you make acetic acid--
vinegar.
That's one of the products.
And then you also make this
very stable acylium ion.
And this acylium
ion is actually--
it's resonance stabilized.
So we can actually take
a pair of electrons
from oxygen, come
down here, and we
can throw the positive charge
out onto the oxygen here.
This is a very stable system.
This is your active electrophile
for this electrophilic aromatic
substitution.
It's your carbonium ion.
So here we've got
the carbonium ion.
And here's our
cyclopentadienide--
the carbanion.
And this carbanion literally
throws its electron density out
to that a acylium
ion and captures it
by the normal steps of
electrophilic aromatic
substitution.
You're just substituting
an electrophile
for a hydrogen on the ring.
And you potentially can
make these two products.
So what you've
got here is you've
got-- you either could
make the monoacetylated
or the diacetylated.
Now after you see
this mechanism--
let's go back here
one more time.
Why can't we put more than
one of these acyl groups
on these rings?
Why can we only make
the mono and the di
as potential products?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
JOHN DOLHUN: Very good.
The acyl group is an
electron withdrawing.
So if you can imagine these
groups pulling electrons away
from the ring, it's creating all
these positive positions here.
And the electrophile
is positive.
So the electrophiles
would be repelled away
from the other positions.
This is a deactivating
group here.
Great.
Now we've got our
products, but we'd
like to know how many
products we've got.
Did we make the monoacetylated
or the diacetylated?
So what we're going
to use is we're
going to use a technique called
thin layer chromatography.
How many of you have done
thin layer chromatography?
Oh wow.
Number of you.
OK.
So what we've got is we've
got these little slides.
They're almost like
microscope slides.
They have a nice clear
surface on one side.
On the other side they
have a solid absorbent.
And the solid absorbants
that we use are alumina--
Al2O3-- and silica gel--
SiO2 times x water.
You notice both of these solid
absorbants have polar bonds.
You've got AlO bonds here.
You've got SiO bonds here.
What that means is the solid
absorbant is going to--
any polar system that
you put on this plate
is going to stick to that
solid absorbent more.
We're also going to
have a mobile phase.
It's going to carry our
components by capillary action
up the plate.
We're going to be spotting
this plate with our product.
And then we're going to watch
the spots move up the plate
and separate by partitioning.
And what does that mean?
In all of these
chromatic distributions
it's all about the
distribution of the solute
between the stationary solid
absorbent and the mobile phase.
And so you can get this
distribution constant,
which actually should
be a constant ideally
over a wide range of
solute concentrations.
Let's say we had a distribution
constant that was very high.
What would that mean in terms
of the spot on the plate?
Yes?
August?
AUDIENCE: It wouldn't
move very far
because most of the material
is the solid [INAUDIBLE]
JOHN DOLHUN: Good.
It wouldn't move very
far on this plate.
It would be sitting
there attached
to that solid absorbent.
And if you had a
column and you were
trying to separate
the material, it
would move slowly through
that column as well.
Good.
So this is what
we're going to do.
Going to use a little jar like
this to run these TLC plates.
Let me just get some board here.
So you are going to
take a TLC plate.
And about 1 centimeter from
the bottom you're going
to draw a line with a pencil--
a straight line-- so use a ruler
because if the line is crooked
your spots are going to be
going in different directions.
We have rulers in the stockroom.
And then what you're
going to do is
you're going to take a
spatula tip of your ferrocene
and a spatula tip of
your diacetyl ferrocene.
And you put them into two
little scintillation vials.
And you go over to the hood.
And what you're going
to do is you're going
to get some dichloromethane.
And you're going to put a
few drops of dichloromethane
into your--
to dissolve your spatula tip.
And then you'll use the
capillary tube to draw that up.
And you'll come back and
you'll spot your plate
with the smallest spot that
you can make and the darkest.
One of the spots will be-- at
least one will be ferrocene
and one will be your
acetylated ferrocene mixture.
That way you can see if
there's any ferrocene
still inside of your
acetylation product.
And then you're going
to take tweezers
and you'll lower
this into the jar.
You'll have your
solvent in the jar.
Put about 2 to 3 mLs of solvent.
Don't put more than 2 to 3 mLs.
I've seen students
put 5, 10, 15 mLs in.
It's way too much.
And then when this
goes down into the jar,
the solvent cannot come up and
touch your spots or your line.
If it does, you've
got to start over.
So you'll put it in the jar
and then you'll kind of just
close it.
And you'll watch it.
You'll watch the
solvent move up.
And then suddenly it's going
to reach up here somewhere.
Then you pull it out
with your tweezers
and you draw another
straight line.
This is the solvent front.
And what we're
going to do is we're
going to calculate what's
known as an Rf value.
It's called a
retardation factor.
And it's a unitless number.
You'll measure from the
starting line to the spot
and then to the
center of the spot
and the starting line to
the solvent front line.
You'll divide that.
You'll get this number.
Ideally, we would like Rf
values somewhere between 0.15
and 0.85, which
means that we want
to get our spots off
the starting line
but not all the way up to
the solvent front line.
We have to pick the solvent.
Let's start out by picking
maybe something non-polar like
hexane--
purely non-polar.
C6H14.
If we pick hexane
as our eluent, what
do you think is going to happen
to the polar component that's
sitting on your line there?
Who said that?
Sean?
It's not going to move at all.
That's right because it's
affixed to that solid absorbent
and it's polar.
It doesn't like this
non-polar solvent.
So it's going to sit
on the starting line.
So this would not
be a good choice.
How about if we pick
something more moderately
polar like ethyl acetate.
Here's ethyl acetate.
So we're going to take this.
And now we're going to
run the plate with this.
What's going to happen to
the non-polar component?
Think about this.
Now you've got ethyl
acetate for your eluent.
You've got a polar
solid absorbent
and your non-polar component.
What will happen to that?
Anyone?
Any of the TAs want
to chime in on this?
Yes, Sean?
AUDIENCE: Maybe it's too
close to the solvent front?
JOHN DOLHUN: Yes.
It's going to zoom all the
way up to the solvent front.
Very good, Sean.
That's exactly what's
going to happen.
So that wouldn't
be good, would it?
We want something in between.
We want to separate
them, but don't want them
all the way to the solvent
front or don't want them
off the starting line.
So here's what
we're going to do.
What I want you to
do is I want you
to try a combination of
ethyl acetate and hexane.
We'll do like a 1:1 mix.
And then do a 4:1 mix.
And then try a 1:4 mix.
I want you to see which
combination gives you the best
separation on your plate.
And once you do that,
then we're going to use
that solvent to run the column.
TLC is just going to tell
us how many components
are in our mixture.
The column will let
us separate them.
So we're actually going to fill
a column with aluminum oxide
and collect our fractions.
Here's a typical column.
Let's pretend we have ferrocene
and acetyl ferrocene in there.
One of them is polar.
One is non-polar.
Which color is the ferrocene?
Yes?
Jesse?
AUDIENCE: Blue.
JOHN DOLHUN: That's you, right?
AUDIENCE: The ferrocene
would be blue.
JOHN DOLHUN: Ferrocene is blue.
Good.
The non-polar is
coming through first
because it's not bound
to the solid absorbent
and it's just flowing
right through.
And you're a acetyl
ferrocene comes after.
So what you're going
to do is you're
going to make a mini column.
Here's an example.
You're going to fill
this with alumina--
about 7 to 8 centimeters
of dry alumina.
And then you're going to
put a little layer of sand
on top of it.
About 5 millimeters
or so of sand.
You can see it here--
get an idea what to do.
And then you're
going to dry load
your sample on top of the sand.
So how do we dry
load our sample?
So what you're going
to do is you're
going to take your
acetylated product,
take it over to the hood, and
you mix in about 50 milligrams
of alumina, and then you
get our old friend out--
dichloromethane.
This is nasty stuff.
It causes all kinds of
cancers in animals--
laboratory animals--
liver, lungs, everything.
So you've got to-- don't
breathe this stuff.
We're keeping it under the hood.
So you add minimal
amount of dichloromethane
just to get this all
wet and a slurry.
And then you use a
nitrogen line to air
dry it to get a nice
powdery air dried product.
And then you're going
to pour your product
on top of that top--
the layer of sand there.
And then you're going to
put another layer of sand
on top of your product--
the final layer.
And then you're ready to go.
What you're going
to do is you're
going to add your solvent
that you picked from TLC that
gave you the best
separation because we
want to separate
these components apart
so we can collect them.
And the thing to remember is
when you add your solvent,
you're ready to go.
Open the stopcock here.
Otherwise, nothing
is going to flow out.
And the other thing I suggest
is get a little scintillation
vials or use the baby
Erlenmeyer flasks
and make sure you weigh
them and tare them
before you do this
reaction because you
may have so little
product it'll be
very hard for you to scrape it
out to get a weight at the end.
But if you weigh the
empty vial first,
then you can weigh it
and get a weight on it
and you'll know your mess so
you can calculate your yield.
Some things that can
happen-- if you have bubbles
in your column, start
over because they're
going to distort your
bands coming through.
If you don't keep the solvent
on top of the top layer of sand
throughout the whole run--
you have to keep a cushion
of solvent flowing--
keep it above that
top layer of sand--
your column will dry out.
It'll crack and your
bands will flow together.
It'll make it difficult to
separate the different colored
bands coming through.
The other thing is when you
make your column, what I do
is tap it a little bit each time
you put the sand and alumina
in.
Make it level so you don't
have these kind of irregular
surfaces that can
cause distortions.
So you're going to take
your melting point,
calculate your percent
yields, determine
the mass of the components,
and that's pretty much
all you need to do for that.
Now I want to show you what's
happening with ferrocene today.
This is really something
with what's going on.
It's been what?
How many years?
51-- it's been almost 70 years.
Right?
OK.
Some people have taken the
penicilloic acid shell that
was synthesized here at MIT
by John Sheehan in the 1950s,
and they acetylated
it with ferrocene
making ferrocenyl penicillin.
And it actually overcomes
some of the resistance that's
developed by the
penicillin antibiotics that
have been around for decades.
Another thing-- someone
has taken tamoxifen--
breast cancer drug that's
been around for decades.
It's become resistant
to a lot of the breast
cancers it's used on.
They've taken the
phenyl group off here,
put ferrocene on,
added and OH group,
and created hydroxy-ferroccifen,
which is also overcoming some
of the resistant breast cancer.
It's really incredible.
This is one of my favorites.
What's the most vicious
animal on the earth?
The mosquito.
Exactly.
I mean, there are two million
deaths by these mosquitoes
with malaria every year.
Chloroquine has been
the source, but it
was discovered in the '30s.
So a lot of resistance.
Right?
So what they've
done to chloroquine
is they've taken
the scaffold here
and they split it and inserted
ferrocene made ferroquine.
This is our fairy queen.
That's good.
Yeah.
Ferroquine-- this could be
the first organo-metallic
antibiotic on the market.
Sanofi Aventis has
pushed this through stage
two clinical trials.
I'm not sure where it is now,
but I got this most recent
paper here.
So this looks very promising.
Testosterone dihydrotestosterone
the nemesis of all men
because the prostate gland, it
grows and then you get cancer.
All men will get cancer
if you live long enough.
So what they've done is they've
made ferrocene derivatives
of these hormones that
block the receptor
site to stop the growth.
This is a good one.
This is just happening.
They took Sedaxane and
they removed this group
and attached ferrocene
and created Sedaxicene.
This is an anti-fungal agent.
And it's relatively non-toxic.
And I mean, you know, these
funguses are out of control.
They've reached
the end of the line
on these fungicides
that can stop them.
So this is a great addition.
I'm not sure where
this is going to go.
And then here is ferrocene
attached to a zinc complex.
And this rivals
the drug cisplatin
in terms of these MCF7
breast cancer cells--
knocking them knocking them out.
So there's a lot of good stuff
happening with ferrocene.
And be sure to take a look at
the safety on the chemicals
here.
The TAs will go
over this with you.
And we'll see you on Thursday
for a very important lecture.
Probably the most important
lecture in the course--
how to write a lab report.
It's all about lab reports.
And Dr. Sarah Hewett
will be giving that.
Thank you.